uh I had a closet hobby since I was a
kid I was a heavy gamer since the word
wasn't even a word and basically to make
a long story short I decided on the
movie Set to make my own math
multiplayer online strategy game and we
decided we we started to develop this
game A year later the game is out it's
doing kind of well at its height uh I
was the founder and CEO of it at its
height it had around 80 employees uh but
the short of it I moved on I opened
another company and a year after that I
understood I need to switch gears I
can't there's something that's not
working for me and I need to switch
[Music]
gears Shahar welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for for
joining me Shahar you're you're
extremely multidisiplinary you're you
have such a unique background in so many
different facets from Taekwondo to
acting and and film and and all the way
to to marketing today with um overwolf
uh an incredible company H one that we
many of us know and and and love and uh
talking about Creator economy gaining
economy this entire world so a a lot for
us to unpack um and and so in order to
do so first I'd love to understand you a
little bit better because I'd love to
understand how all these things are
coming in together and then we will
spend time talking about over wealth and
the gaming world so tell me a little bit
about yourself your upbringing and how
you gods and here okay I'll give you
kind of a a quick quick grab of all the
sorts of uh uh no pannies I visited so I
was born and raised in Jerusalem in the
city itself and in the outskirts young
age I was a professional martial artist
five times Israel national champion
competed worldwide ranked um military a
little bit of everything um and then
when I left I started my studies for BA
and Ma but I became an actor on TV and
film um also opened my own martial art
gyms and had students and I was very
busy between TV and martial arts at some
point I sold a TV show to the states and
moved to Los Angeles to to make it the
show never got done but I got into the
industry there um and at some point on a
set I'm shooting a movie on a set with
with uh with a bunch of uh well-known
movie stars uh I had a closet hobby
since I was a kid uh I was a gamer I was
a heavy gamer since the word wasn't even
a word uh and and I it was a nerdy type
of of hobby um but I kept uh gaming all
my life it started from the 80s into the
90s and then when I was shooting I
started playing strategy MMOs and
basically to make a long story short I
decided on the movie Set to make my own
massive multiplayer online strategy game
web based and when I got back to LA I
teamed up uh with a partner and and and
a and a game design student from USC and
we decided we we started to develop this
game again a cut a year later the game
is out it's doing kind of well uh and
and then we managed to raise uh a bunch
of money some of it came from Israel uh
with a request that we come back to
Israel which was starting to become a
gaming powerhouse on the Casual Casino
side to to build a company so I went
back
um back went back to Israel about a
decade ago and open seven element
Studios um and at its height uh I was
the founder and CEO of it at its height
it had around 80 employees you know wow
whatever whatever you think about you
know a happening um a happening uh a
happening Studio brought two MMO titles
to Market almost got bought for a
significant amount of money from by an
American publisher but the end when the
deal when the deal didn't didn't didn't
kind of failed at the last moment or
past um I managed to I decided to move
on uh I'm gonna all all of these little
stories can can open into massage
stories uh but the short of it I moved
on I opened another company uh with one
of my board members who's very wellknown
VC in Israel and a year after that I
understood I need to switch gears I
can't there's something that's not
working for me and I need to switch
gears and I became an adviser to
multiple startups and CEOs primarily
starting to develop my own kind of
system on how you tell a story of a
company but not just the storytelling
aspect of it at that point I've raised
tens of millions of dollars so I've i'
I've figured out a way to make the room
work for you VC wise also inside the
company kind of alignment of values and
vision and Mission with actual
deliverables so I would say a story with
roots not just
that's just a story you tell which kind
of percolated through the debts and the
way the company worked and the product
and the tech uh and it I managed to help
a few startups do really well uh and one
of the startups I worked with was
overwolf uh particularly with RI marshan
the the the the founder and one of the
co-founder and CEO and I really L the
work there uh exceptional people really
the best of the best a very deep sense
of uh values and Mission and and humble
and at some point a year and a half in
when a lot of the things we were working
on started to really take off I decided
to come in and help the company uh as a
CMO but I also lead IR in the company
I'm the investor relations officer so I
be with a bunch of uh VCS and backs and
whatnot that are interested comp um so
that's where you're meeting me right now
um and I guess this snack of really
helping uh um marketing and Market wise
to tell a company's story but also to
amplify it by a Performance
Tools uh is what brings me to this
position and doing it
successfully wow okay so I I want to now
look into the gaming world and and this
is a world in which it feels that
there's it's obviously one of the most
incredible markets that are emerging
undoubtedly and didn't grow up as a
gamer but allowed myself to be immer in
this Mark and in this category um both
as a sort of Entry gamer but also as a
technology Enthusiast and as a friends
Enthusiast and and let help me
understand a little bit about what's
been happening here over the last few
years what what is this world that we're
living in with gaming
um so so there's a few layers to that
question I yeah go as as a as a lifelong
gamer and a martial art Enthusiast and
PE and a person also touch on touches on
for lack of a better word I'll say on
the spiritual uh spiritual side of life
with mindfulness and all sorts of other
things I think that we are living in a
very confused world where a lot of
people have some sort of a breakdown to
the sense making mechanisms that they
grow up in and around whatever is in
them and around them and I think that
gains offer a great platform for you to
sense make yourself in so when
everything else collapses around you
when we're moving in in the direction of
dystopia all the the environments that
help you um find your purpose your
narrative that are very clear on how you
can level up in them that give you also
the ability to really merge and
experience with I think all and that is
games they become super
intensified uh and there's good good
reasons for that and there's bad reasons
or more challenging reasons of of of
effects that can come from that but in
general gaming is the ultimate sense
making platform where people can spend
time and get things in in Clarity and
experience things that they cannot today
in the outer world so it's just growing
and growing and it will continue to grow
it's a COR that's going to continue to
grow so what but in primarily in in in
kind of the mid to hardcore experiences
of it and
also it will it will it will bleed into
everything so we're already seeing that
games are synonymous with the word
entertainment but this is just going to
to accelerate I don't know if you have
kids my uh my eight-year-old Ben is just
spending most of his free time in Roblox
and Minecraft and all these ecosystems
where he has his best friends that's
what they do they communicate they find
each other there uh and I think that's
that's part of this this whole shift on
the demographic so you know from a
sociological philosophical standpoint
that's why gains are going to continue
to um in particular in in and I'm going
to bring it a little bit into overwolf
there's some tectonic shifts that happen
in the world of gaming one of them per
contains to what overwolf is doing and
that's in the user generated content the
ugc area now when I say ugc ugc has two
tracks it has a performance track where
you can see streamers and content
producers and that's mostly what people
think about when they say ugc but I'm
what I in this conversation what I refer
to is the actual creators this
third-party independent creators that
produce develop design products add-ons
mods applications private servers in and
around popular games now what we've seen
happen in in in the last few years is is
a sort of tectonic shift where ugc which
was once uh a taboo for game studios
game studios specifically the big titles
or any titles they don't want anybody to
touch their IP or to mess around with IP
uh there's a few exceptions to that but
majority that's the sentiment of the big
Publishers they are now opening up to to
have a conversation with third party
creators and third party creators are a
very different animal these are you know
Renegade or just people that love the
game uh could be hackers could be
developers could be you know just Shin
Gamers that have some sense and they
want to bring something to the game so
where in the past it was just uh was
shut down today we're seeing more and
more acceptance of that in the market I
I think you could see that you know when
when
it was all intensified by the you know
the Roblox IPO success of Minecraft and
games that are ugc based at their core
where you give players the ability to um
to experience many different types of of
game experiences but I think that also
due to them and other changes in the
market the demand side from the user
side or constant content has increased
substantially so uh if when I played a
game or back in the day you would play a
game you would finish it you would just
play it again and again and again you
wouldn't have any expectations to have
anything happen to it or or for more
content that's that coming from the the
publisher today it's different um and we
see fullon
ecosystems
that that the the the you the third
party generated the uh um environment
has more playtime in it and this is
where overwolf enters the picture
overwolf believes that
playtime in and around games is going to
be leaning towards the ugc side as we as
we move forward into the future meaning
uh you would play more time eventually
in the ugc aspect than in the core game
or the vanilla game and we want to
empower third party creators or in-game
creators as we call them
to make a creation a profession and we
have a business model that allows for
creators third party creators to make uh
uh make a living out of their Creations
which is it never happened before um and
and just to to just to give a little bit
of perspective of the market so there's
one big uh game or game ecosystem called
Roblox that is a very specific type of
an ecosystem it's hugely successful over
70 million daily active users that's
massive but aside from Roblox and you
have of course Epic uh uh starting to
push in this direction but aside from
these two specific environments you
have uh you you have a market that needs
servicing and that's what overwolf is is
is is there to do it wants to help all
the game studios where they are to ugc
to help them uh incorporate ugc into
their games and we do that by providing
a Zero to Hero solution for any game
Studio from the actual Tech of bringing
it to their game from community commity
tools uh moderation
curation um we've built a very robust
moderation and curation uh uh service in
overwolf which for the big studios is a
big thing because you cannot as you can
imagine when you open the gates to third
party creators they are B players that
want
to that that that want to perhaps uh uh
use and abuse so we've we're kind of the
experts on on on being
the incredible now when you when you
talk about your role so there's the
there's the there's the market of the
the gaming there's the trend the macro
trend of ugc of of Gamers spending time
in ugc versus the vanilla and then
there's the creators who Empower and and
are the enablers of the ugc content and
you see yourself as the Guild of in-game
creators right so it it's it to me that
immediately resonates as a community
play You're creating something that's
bigger than the individual it's beyond
just a developer tool talk to me a
little bit about this the community
aspect here so I I think that I mean for
for anything to happen I mean one of the
biggest aspects of getting a community
or getting ugc to work around a game is
to know how to facilitate and service
the community in a way that inspires
them to not only create but also help
each other create and kind of help us
Foster the communication between them
and uh in the game Studio at large a
good example would be now with a game we
just launched with Studio Wild Card Arc
survival ascended so Ark survival
ascended is a game that launched on PC
and now also on Xbox and PS5 it's
crossplatform and it's also crossplay in
terms of modding for the first time so
just a little bit about the game I don't
know if you know Arc or not check it out
it's a very popular game I would say
dinosaurs with Bazookas would be would
be the thing but it's a heavily modded
game and it has a massive modding
Community outside and part of our job
was to inspire that Community to come
inside the game and we start to work
specifically with the creators
themselves but we also with the studio
align incentives on creation which which
are things that didn't really happen
before so we opened a new Creator
category from that game which is also
game studios we have game studios
creating DLC level mods meaning that now
you could play Arc but you could also
download soon to be it's not out yet
it's going to be out later this quarter
uh our DLC level mod which means that
the gain itself becomes this engine of
content that content can be released on
um and in that sense you can only do
that when you kind of manage to
facilitate cooperation between the game
Studio the community you manage to
standardize the connection but also
standardize it in terms of best
practices okay how do I what do I do how
do I do it what what we also manage to
do which is extremely there's a lot of
behind the scenes taxing H assignments
like to get a mod working on Xbox you
need certification for instance so we
take care of that for the modder now so
suddenly their ability to deploy on all
these platforms is exponentially as
exponentially grown because that back in
the day they would need to approach exp
which would never respond and there's
all these broken links and part of what
we're doing is standardizing these
things so it's a it's a it's a plethora
of actual Services which is Tech in hand
that is useful but also relationships
and community so we you know I'm taking
Studio wild card as an example because
we have a great relationship with them
we have you know weekly syns on all
various levels we talk with our creators
we do Town Halls we're constantly
working in making this community gel but
also
pushing pushing their Creations out and
trying to help them create the best
creations they can and then also Market
them to
Gamers so it's kind of a cohesive EOS a
cohesive ecosystem of various products
that comes together to facilitate the
rise of the end game creator and and
what is this for you bringing the
bringing this concept and bringing the
the messaging and the the these ideals
to the community Through the
communication and through the and on
behalf of the company what has this been
like for
you so for me I'm I I was always about
doing things
around
vitalizing you know vitalizing uh uh I I
want to say civilization but it's a bit
too big I really love to be and help
people kind of step up and bring their
Vision into into the world and and with
games being such a core uh uh in in my
in my personal Brew prad it's it's it's
I find it as a privilege and also kind
of a mission to help these sometimes
it's these low in-game creators you know
there's a guy in England or a guy
somewhere in the states or in Germany
that they don't know they have something
they brought something great but they
can't bring it to the Forefront and
through our platform today not only can
they bring it to the Forefront but they
can also if it's really successful make
a living out of it that's that's a big
game game changer for someone in their
life and and that's a mission that
really inspires me personally uh as I
move you know to touch a life
individually is is an aspiring thing and
in this particular way um I I think
there's still a lot to do I think uh I
think some of the big gaming Studios
understand they need to bring it and
they need to build a ugc strategy and
and ecosystem around their game but
there's still it's it's it's just in its
infancy
um last year we worked with EA on the
sin 4 which now is extremely popular on
curseforge.com which is uh which is
another website of a full wolf so it's
it's happening it's already happening um
I I have this uh I have this this uh
paper on the Four Horsemen of the ugc
Apocalypse one is the four first Foreman
is the demand the market demands change
constantly uh The Sims is a good example
because it doesn't matter what Maxis the
game Studio puts out they their gamers
are so amped on the game they constantly
want more stuff out and they just can't
keep up with the demand um but that's
true to many games today um the other
one is is uh standardization which is
game studios now understanding they need
to bring it and we're kind of bridging
it um the first the third one is the
growth there's a massive growth in in in
the industry and the fourth one is
tools which is you know it could be
Lumen and baking tools of 3D and and ufn
it could be with us all sorts of tools
that are coming that help creators AI of
course and all that kind of stuff um so
phenomenal shakal I want to thank you
for the time this was so so interesting
and I feel like I got a a really good
Deep dive into your world which
obviously you've been a part of for many
years as a gamer and as a disciplin but
now also as a leader both from the
entrepreneurial side yourself and and
leading Studios and running companies in
this regard but now also from from the
marketing side you know taking a company
an incredible company raised more than
$150 million from incredible investors
some of the best in the world being at
The Cutting Edge of not only the
categorical shift but also the
technological um implementations but and
and looking at how do you build a
community of now those that the
individuals that Empower this this
category to rise and emerge as there's a
shift in consumer Behavior your towards
ugc contemp so fascinating stuff thank
you so much for joining me best of luck
with everything you do and I'm excited
to continue being a fan from the side so
thank you thank you Michel thank you
appreciate thank
[Music]
you